eeuu se prepara para el primer debate
presidencial entre el mandatario donald
trump y su rival demócrata joe biden y
se prevé estará cargado de alta tensión
a la gestión de las pandemias de
coronavirus y la ola de manifestaciones
anti racistas se suman nuevas y
recientes polémicas ampliaremos desde
washington
y los incendios en california eeuu no
dan tregua
miles de personas fueron evacuadas por
un nuevo foco que arrasó con viviendas y
viñedos al menos otras tres personas
murieron y los decesos ya son más de 35
desde que comenzaron las conflagraciones
y el presidente de francia de manual
macrón se comprometió a mediar en la
crisis y bielorrusa durante un encuentro
en lituania con la líder opositora este
tras la tica nobbs cai exiliada en este
país tras las polémicas elecciones
presidenciales del 9 de agosto señaladas
de fraudulentas
buenos días bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 saludamos a toda nuestra
audiencia muchas gracias por
acompañarnos como siempre yo santiago
ariztía y comenzamos esta emisión en
eeuu que hoy será el escenario del tan
esperado primer debate presidencial
entre el mandatario de donald trump y su
rival demócratas yo bailé en que se
prevé estará cargado de altas tensiones
a 5 semanas de las elecciones de los
candidatos se medirán este martes ante
las cámaras y ante millones de personas
que lo seguirán a lo largo de todo el
mundo a temas que se prevé y van que
iban a abordarse como la polémica
gestión de la pandemia de coronavirus y
la ola de masivas protestas anti
racistas se suman ahora a tensiones
recientes como las revelaciones sobre
las declaraciones de impuestos del
mandatario de donald trump y también la
polémica por el reemplazo elegido por
para la fallecida jueza de la corte
suprema ruth báder ginsburg que han
estallado durante las últimas semanas y
no se pierdan hoy a las 20 horas de
bogotá quito y lima nuestro programa
especial dedicado a este tan esperado
debate con toda la información y
análisis de expertos invitados
y para ampliar la información vamos ya
mismo a washington para hablar con
nuestra corresponsal diana castañeda muy
buenos días diana contanos hacia donde
estará dirigida no principalmente la
agenda del debate ha dado un vuelco esta
agenda en los últimos días no con temas
nuevos como el reemplazo de ruth báder
ginsburg entre otros
hola buen día pues este debate que
durará tiene 66 segmentos de 15 minutos
que será de manera inusual no se
estrecharán las manos debido a la
pandemia tiene varios temas centrales
uno de ellos es kobe 19 la respuesta que
cada uno de los candidatos tienen sus
plataformas para hacer frente a esta
crisis al desempleo y volver a tener
trabajos en los estadounidenses también
otro de los temas centrales por supuesto
será la economía pero igualmente el tema
de la igualdad racial después de las
grandes protestas que se registraron en
toda la nación exigiendo cambios y
reformas al interior de los
departamentos de policía igualmente es
muy posible que veamos preguntas sobre
la declaración de impuestos de donald
jones y el gran escándalo que ha
generado debido a la cantidad tan baja
que ha tenido que pagar el presidente en
materia de impuestos otro de los temas
serán la corte suprema- y lo que
califican los demócratas e incluso el
presidente
de los eeuu como una urgencia para
nombrar a un nuevo miembro y que sea
aprobado por el senado al interior de la
corte suprema así que será una mezcla de
los temas principales de seguridad
nacional pero también de los temas más
polémicos que han generado rivalidad
entre los dos partidos y vienen a
contarnos cómo sigue a cada candidato a
este debate en términos de imagen de
aceptación pública
bueno las últimas encuestas muestran que
yo bailé me lleva a una ventaja de entre
6 a 7 puntos a donald trump a nivel
nacional sin embargo esto varía por
estados por ejemplo en florida el
presidente de donald trump le lleva una
ventaja de tres puntos a bailén y es un
estado clave para ganar las elecciones
presidenciales por ejemplo para el voto
latino la última encuesta de esta semana
muestra que definitivamente vaivenes
lleva una ventaja más amplia de 42
puntos pero hay 26% de los latinos que
votarían por donald trump sobre todo
como lo mencionaba en el estado de
florida así que los dos candidatos se
llevan a enfrentarse en este tan
esperado debate el presidente en medio
de críticas por el manejo que ha dado a
esta pandemia y bailén fortalecido
también por esta desventaja que tiene el
mandatario de tener digamos estas
dolorosas cifras de ser el líder a nivel
mundial con más muertes
por una virosis casos alrededor del
mundo ya nada que tenía muchísimas
gracias por este completísimo reporte
desde washington eeuu continuamos en
este país porque miles de personas
debieron ser evacuadas en california por
un nuevo foco de incendios que se ha
propagado en las últimas 48 horas esta
vez las zonas afectadas son los condados
de napa y de sonoma famoso por su
extensa producción vinícola que por
supuesto también se ha visto seriamente
afectada por la destrucción de varias
bodegas y además en las últimas horas al
menos otras tres personas fallecieron en
un nuevo foco al norte del estado los
detalles en el informe de álvaro cordero
el valle de napa corazón de la región
vinícola por excelencia de california
también está siendo devorado por los
incendios las llamas han consumido más
de 4.500 hectáreas de los condados de
napa y sonoma donde se han alcanzado los
39 grados centígrados y vientos de 80
kilómetros por hora en los últimos días
miles de vecinos se tuvieron que marchar
de sus casas con urgencia
estuvo muy cerca el tráfico estaba
congestionado fue una locura salir de
aquí luego una vez pude regresar fue un
alivio ver que algunas de nuestras cosas
todavía estaban aquí pero fue una noche
aterradora fue una locura
las imágenes tomadas por los ciudadanos
durante su vida en automóvil muestran la
gravedad del momento las llamas
bordeaban la carretera que utilizaron
para escapar durante el día los focos
llegaron hasta los suburbios de santa
rosa la principal ciudad afectada en
total hasta 2.200 viviendas se
calcinaron por los incendios baja o se
reforma mi casa hasta un cuarto de milla
de la carretera en juego el mountain
road y el incendio estaba a unos 100
metros de mi casa así que ahora mismo
estamos esperando que los bomberos
puedan ganar la batalla la costa oeste
de eeuu atraviesa la peor oleada de
incendios de su historia que hasta el
momento se estima que ha terminado con
la vida de al menos 38 personas y ha
carbonizado más de 26 millones de
hectáreas
y el presidente de francia de manuel
ground se reunió con la líder opositora
de belarús alternative kaya este martes
en lituania donde ella está exiliada
después de haber participado en las
polémicas elecciones presidenciales del
9 de agosto macrón prometió su ayuda al
pueblo bielorruso después de más de 50
días de protestas en el país y miles de
detenciones
es la primera vez en 19 años que un
presidente francés viaja a lituania para
una visita bilateral sin embargo no es
lituania sino belarús el centro de las
discusiones en una reunión con la líder
de la oposición bielorrusa exiliada
svetlana ticas busca ya macrón dijo que
francia seguirá ofreciendo su apoyo al
movimiento prodemocracia
nos prometió hacer todo lo posible por
ayudar en las negociaciones durante esta
crisis política en nuestro país
y dijo que el tiempo es crucial porque
mucha gente está sufriendo por esto
mucha gente está en la cárcel y él hará
todo lo posible para liberar a todos los
presos políticos
pero es un delicado acto de equilibrio
para el presidente francés queriendo
ayudar a belarús mientras intenta no
provocar la ira de moscú en oposición de
sus hijos sin rulon con nuestra manera
de verlo es que si queremos construir
una paz sostenible en el continente
europeo tenemos que trabajar con rusia
porque compartimos una historia hay una
geografía
no podemos actuar como si europa fuera
una isla lejana a rusia
el líder ruso vladimir putin ha dicho
que belarús se enfrenta a una presión
externa sin precedentes y por el momento
francia está actuando sola la unión
europea aunque condena la violencia no
ha impuesto sanciones macro no ha pedido
que la organización para la seguridad y
la cooperación en europa se haga cargo
de la mediación en el conflicto y en
otras noticias la lucha entre las
fuerzas de armenia azerbaiyán y los
separatistas del enclave de nagorno
karabaj no dan tregua llegan a su tercer
día las partes usaron ataques aéreos
dejando docenas de muertos este lunes el
martes francia llamó a los miembros del
grupo de minsk el idea junto a eeuu y a
rusia para abordar de manera urgente
esta situación veamos el informe de
matías a raíz
el sonido de los bombardeos se escuchó
durante todo el día a medida que la
lucha continúa los residentes locales
están soportando el peso tanto las
fuerzas azerbaiyanas como las armenias
se han mostrado muy interesadas en
reflejar cómo se golpean mutuamente con
los ataques aéreos las muertes están
aumentando en ambos lados en la capital
de azerbaiján los hombres están haciendo
fila para alistarse como militares
aunque nuestro ejército es fuerte vine
aquí para mostrarle a nuestro gobierno
que estoy listo estamos listos para
proteger nuestra patria en cualquier
momento en las calles de ereván los
armenios muestran reacciones mixtas y
nihat no queremos una guerra pero si se
nos impone lucharemos no está en vano
quiero que todas las partes vuelvan a la
mesa de negociaciones lo único que
quiero es la paz me van golpes
el último estallido de este largo
conflicto comenzó el domingo en el
enclave de nagorno karabaj declarado
parte de azerbayán cuando se disolvió la
unión soviética pero que ha permanecido
en gran medida bajo el control de los
separatistas de etnia armenia
respaldados por el gobierno o la guerra
total terminó con un alto el fuego
negociado por rusia en 1994 pero aún no
se ha firmado ningún acuerdo de paz
formal
el secretario general exhortó
enérgicamente a las partes a que cesaran
inmediatamente los combates redujeron
las tensiones y volvieran a entablar
negociaciones significativas sin
condiciones previas ni retrasar el
consejo de seguridad de la onu celebra
conversaciones de emergencia a puerta
cerrada este martes para tratar de
buscar una salida a las hostilidades en
curso en el día de acción global por el
acceso al aborto legal y seguro miles de
mujeres latinoamericanas alzaron sus
voces nuevamente para exigir a sus
gobiernos políticas públicas que
garantice sus derechos mujeres de
argentina el salvador ecuador méxico y
otros países de américa latina y el
caribe se manifestaron
en las calles y esta vez la marea verde
se trasladó también al ciberespacio por
la pandemia de coronavirus un contexto
que según muchas mujeres agudizó aún más
los conflictos en el acceso a la salud
sexual y reproductiva algunas marcharon
otras se instalaron frente a los
parlamentos de sus países y muchas más
organizaron pañuelazos virtuales para
pedir que el aborto deje de ser
clandestino
vamos ahora a uruguay que vive por estos
días una inusual ola de peticiones de
residencia y se ha más de 20 mil
argentinos han hecho la solicitud esto
es una respuesta a un decreto emitido
por el presidente luis lacalle pou que
facilita el asentamiento de extranjeros
en el país y vamos ya mismo a montevideo
para ampliar esta información con
nuestra corresponsal y karina de alma
karina muy buenos días contanos por qué
están tan atraídos quienes están
haciendo las solicitudes de residencia
santiago muy buenos días buenos
uruguayos argentinos compartimos muchos
usos y costumbres y por supuesto tenemos
fuertes lazos económicos y culturales ya
desde hace muchos años de la fundación
de nuestros países en estos momentos
argentina que tiene una población de más
de 40 millones de personas está
registrando más de 16.000 fallecidos por
el coronavirus mientras en uruguay donde
nuestra población es de más de 3
millones casi tres millones y medio de
personas registramos 50 menos de 50
fallecidos por el coronavirus y esto ha
generado una atrás que haya sido más
atractivo el país para venir a recibir
de hecho en uruguay como tú ya sabes no
tenemos cuarentena obligatoria y la
mayoría de las actividades económicas se
encuentran en normalidad dentro del
marco de las medidas sanitarias por el
cobat 19 de hecho la cámara inmobiliaria
de uruguay ha dicho que se han
registrado múltiples solicitudes y de
hecho ha incrementado las compraventas
de parte de argentinos así también lo
han indicado los colegios privados donde
recordemos en uruguay sa se encuentran
en clases presenciales y en tiempo
completo esto ha sido un llamador para
las familias argentinas reina del
presidente de uruguay lacalle pou dijo
que se necesitaba más gente en su
territorio cuál es la razón
bueno el el presidente lacalle pou ya en
enero antes de asumir dijo que iba a
implementar medidas para impulsar la
economía y también la generación de
empleo entre ellas la flexibilización de
la residencia fiscal de extranjeros dijo
que uruguay podría recibir 100 mil
familias y esto generar muy cosas
positivas para la economía uruguaya es
así que redujo estaba siendo presidente
por ejemplo los requisitos de invertir
bajaron de 3.5 millones de dólares a 300
mil a 70 mil dólares y también menos
días 60 días de residencia y que se
genere 15 puestos de trabajo esto ha
generado una flexibilización para la
residencia fiscal no es tan fácil traer
las empresas pero algunos ya están
tomando estas medidas que harina
muchísimas gracias por este reporte
finalizamos esta emisión informativa
sigan en france 24
[Música]